et place maintenant à soir 3 politique
dans soir 3 politique francis letellier
reçoit jean luc mélenchon député
européen porte parole du parti de gauche
au moment où le fn et marine le pen se
retrouvent au centre du débat politique
quelle riposte à porter et pour 2012
quel rôle a peu joué le front de gauche
à côté du ps bonsoir jean luc mélenchon
bonsoir le polémiques font l'actualité
on va commencer par celle qu'a lancé
brice hortefeux qui a soutenu des
policiers condamnés par le tribunal de
bobigny pour avoir rédigé de faux
procès-verbaux aujourd'hui ministre de
la justice lui a répliqué à est à
rappeler que la justice était
indépendante mais brice hortefeux dit
lui je persiste et signe à soutenir les
policiers
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'anormal à ce qu'un
ministre de l'intérieur soutienne ces
policiers parce que le rôle du ministre
de l'intérieur et pas d'être le chef du
syndicat de la police le chef du
syndicat
les responsables syndicaux policiers
peuvent avoir défendre leur collègue
d'avoir une opinion sur le sujet mais un
ministre de l'intérieur qui est le
numéro 2 ou 3 du gouvernement en général
lui il a en charge la république et dans
la république le ministre de l'intérieur
défend pas des gens qui ont condamné par
la justice voilà est-ce qu'il ya
réellement
est-ce qu'il ya réellement une guerre
police justice en france je ne sais pas
mais ce qui est grave dans tout ça c'est
de voir à quel point le pouvoir est
fébrile à quel point il affaiblit lui
même toutes les institutions entre un
président de la république qui tord le
bras aux deux assemblées pour faire
passer une loi sur les retraites
un ministre de l'intérieur qui s'en
prend au système de la justice celui de
la justice qui lui répond je pense que
tous ces gens sont en train de
fragiliser la république dans ses
institutions comme avant ils l'ont ils
l'ont fragilisée dans dans son esprit ce
débat épouvantable sur l'identité
nationale
ces bêtises offert l'errance et de de
plusieurs générations
une autre polémique à la suite des
propos maintenant de marine le pen qui a
comparé les prières des musulmans dans
les rues à l'occupation lors de la
seconde guerre mondiale est ce que c'est
un dérapage ou plus que ça c'est madame
la famille le pen c'est le diable de
gros fort
du système heureusement qu'ils sont là
parce que sinon il manquerait on a
l'impression que quand ils y sont pas
bons les faire revivre l'autre soir
cette soirée pitoyable sous la houlette
de madame chabot l'on avait une fois de
plus éliminer le front de gauche on a
pendant une heure et demie donné
l'occasion à madame le pen d'être là au
milieu du tableau je vais vous résumer
ça nous avons fait la rentrée et deux
mois sur la lutte de classe avec les
travailleurs les ouvriers qui venait sur
la scène qui posait le problème de la
finance des banques
heureusement il ya vadam le pen ça y est
on va pouvoir revenir aux vieux débat
sur les musulmans les pas musulmans la
religion en politique
j'essaie tout simplement que c'est la
faute aux autres vous est permis presque
marine le pen a mais je vous m'aurait
malentendu je viens de vous dire que
elle elle est dans son rôle
elle est là pour ça pour faire des
diversions religieuses ethniques et le
système médiatico-politique la met en
avant parce qu'il préfère parler de ça
que de parler des banques du rôle de la
finance et des deux comme on vient de le
voir pendant trois mois ce sont ces la
classe ouvrière qui s'est moqué monter
sur la scène
est ce que vous avez entendu parler une
seule fois pendant les trois derniers
mois de savoir qui faisait la prière et
comment alors après on peut entrer dans
le détail
personne n'aime que l'espace public soit
occupé par les religieux alors que ce
soit les uns ou les autres
mais vous avez des indignations moi je
me dis tout le temps c'est à dire que ce
soit un tibétain
où que ce soit à musulman où que ce soit
un catholique
je suis contre la religion dans l'espace
public mais là bon évidemment le mrap a
décidé de porter plainte
est-ce qu'il faut introduire une action
en justice même au plus haut niveau et a
dit non mais moi je ne je pense que si
le mrap le fait c'est qu'il a des
raisons de le faire et il est dans son
rôle maintenant nous dans le temps dans
la représentation politique la question
est de savoir si nous allons continuer à
sauter à la corde
chaque fois que elle se livre à une
provocation qui va lui permettre de ne
pas parler des sujets dont tous veulent
avoir parlé parce que madame le pen en
train de défendre des travailleurs pour
quelqu'un qui est partisan de la
retraite à 67 ans il ya quand même
quelque chose qui est un peu bidon et
pourtant on l'a mis en scène bombay
vient de là
quand même quelque chose dessus pour
terminer qui doit vous rassurer c'est
que à droite comme à gauche tout le
monde dit stop au front national
non mais ça c'est bidon c'est des
paroles ils sautent ils bondissent
il met en scène vous avez à la une du
monde un grand papier qui dit en gros
tous ceux qui sont contre l'euro qui ont
des critiques à faire son pour madame le
pen on l'amène sur les plateaux pour la
présenter comme le diable de confort
parce qu'après je vais vous dire ce qui
va se passer
l'ump dira il faut surtout pas disperser
les voix attention madame le pen va être
à notre place au 2e tour et puis les
socialistes diront il faut surtout pas
disperser les voix parce que madame le
pen va prendre notre place comme en 2002
donc c'est le diable de confort les deux
compères s'entende avec une clé pour
mettre en route le petit moteur et cette
clé s'appelle le pen
une fois qu'on met la clé le pen on a
droit au vote utile et à la sortie
et bien c'est toujours les mêmes alors
est ce que patrice machuret du service
politique de françois va nous rejoindre
maintenant que marine le pen semble
s'installer malgré tout dans le paysage
politique que vous le regrettiez vous
nous l'avez dit est ce qu'elle devient
c'est la question la troisième force
patrick on peut dire que marine le pen
c'est une plante carnivore une plante
qui se nourrit de la peur de l'autre
sur fond de chômage et d'insécurité elle
ressort la théorie du bouc émissaire
c'est immigrés qui ne s'intègrent pas
vous l'avez dit vous avez rappelé 1 et
qui occupent les rues pour prier ce
dérapage volontaire montre que marine le
pen n'est pas sûre d'elle pas sûr de
prendre la présidence du parti
le vote des militants qui vient de
commencer pour élire le successeur de
jean-marie le pen finalement doit
l'inquiéter jugé trop lisse la candidate
a voulu donner des gages à la ligne dure
aux historiques du parti comme son père
elle joue la provocation verbale du
populisme à l'ancienne est comme son
père depuis des mois elle surfe aussi
sur la crise morale le tous pourris
une posture anti système qui réussit
plutôt bien aux extrêmes tout comme pour
vous d'une certaine façon jean luc
mélenchon ça monte dans les sondages la
fille le pen lan mais aussi un allié
inespéré la droite le virage sécuritaire
de nicolas sarkozy à crédibiliser le
discours de l'extrême droite
hier jean françois copé a continué le
patron de l'ump veut relancer le débat
sur l'identité nationale
ce débat qui a remis en selle l'an
dernier un front national moribond
une idée d'ailleurs salué ça prouve que
ya la bad
dès aujourd'hui par les ministres
hortefeux et besson
en somme pour se protéger de la grippe
la droite préconise de l'attraper jean
luc mélenchon alors pour vous relancer
le débat sur l'identité nationale pour
contrer la remontée du front ou de
marine le pen est ce que c'est une bonne
idée ça a l'air de vous conduire à
puisque vous même vous relayez ça dans
votre éditorial vous parler de populisme
pourquoi vous dites pas fascisme ne
savais pas que front national c'est un
système le fascisme n'ai pas lu leurs
textes nom vous dit populiste parce que
l'instant d'après ça vous permet de dire
que moi aussi je peux un populiste est
comme ça vous avez organisé votre petit
paysage avec les deux parties censées
vous êtes les héros créés elle est
présentée comme une personne pouvant sur
l'extrême gauche capté aussi des voix du
front national
mais moi je m'adresse comme tout le
front de gauche à tous les français et
je leur propose une sortie de crise par
le haut par la lutte contre la finance
pour moi l'ennemi c'est le financier
le banquier tous ceux qui ruinent
l'économie pour madame le pen c'est
l'arabe le juif ça dépend des jours
d'accord donc nous n'avons rien à voir
monsieur jean-luc trial sur le dérapage
c'est un des rares villes qui aussi très
direct ils mènent leur guerre iman leur
guerre c'est leur intérêt de faire ça à
elle de trouver un nouvel un nouveau
bouc émissaire et pas l'évoquer et à
monsieur copé de se trouver un diable de
confort pour dire mais attendez c'est
nous l'apprend qu'il reste comme si la
france était tous allez vite vous ne
sortira pas de ce débat leur on reprend
les neiges l'heure actuelle puisque vous
même vous avez un peu tendance à vous
arrêter
on comprend les égouts les défendent pas
réglés pour 2012 quelles sont les
conditions pour vous soyez candidat à la
présidentielle parce que tout est en
rapport avec le sujet absolument passe à
autre chose vous fera mais on comprend
que vous payez défendre ces idées là bas
les conditions sont en train de moi
personnellement voulait dire alors ça
c'est c'est 700 concours 2 il y aura
beaucoup de circonstances qui
interviendront moi j'ai dit que j'étais
disponible suis pas le seul bon voilà
nos parties feront des propositions afin
les communistes a aussi un candidat donc
quand ce sera tranché comment alors on
va on va en parler
bientôt ils ont leur calendrier nous
avons le nôtre non tout ça de ce côté là
il y aura pas le les clowneries les
primaires et tout ça c'est pas pour nous
tout ça non ce qui est ce qui peut
réaliser des bonnes conditions de de
cette candidature commune du front de
gauche c'est ça qui est important c'est
que vous aurez une candidature du front
de gauche qui est pas une candidature
populistes ou extrémistes c'est une
candidature de gauche pour toute la
gauche et pour tout le peuple français
voilà et les gens auront à se dire ben
entre l'à-peu-près et hulu le strauss
kahn fmi où le front de gauche basque
qui sont de gauche où se calme le pays
et qui aimeraient qu'on en sort par le
haut bas ils choisiront alors justement
vous parliez des primaires du ps
notamment qui continue de faire parler
au parti socialiste notamment où
dominique strauss kahn est le sujet de
ce spectacle permanent au carrelet mois
là c'est le sujet de préoccupation à
sion ps dominique strauss kahn le fmi
mènent des politiques qui pour moi sont
des politiques contre les populations
que irlande par exemple dans le plan de
sauvetage de son économie et de ses
banques n'est pas rehausser le niveau de
l'impôt sur les sociétés est un scandale
si lui n'a pas envie de revenir et de
plongée dans une campagne présidentielle
ce que je dis si ce que je redis très
clairement devant vous et très fermement
c'est que d'une façon ou d'une autre si
je suis élue puisqu'on me posez la
question dans cette hypothèse si je suis
élue présidente de la république
bien évidemment mon souhait le plus cher
c'est que dominique apporte sa
compétence pour permettre de lutter
contre la crise financière
internationale
jean luc mélenchon quel serait le
meilleur candidat du ps avec lequel vous
souhaiteriez le plus négocier
éventuellement en 2012 vous discutez pas
négocier dit cela il ya deux cas il ya
le cas où c'est le candidat du front de
gauche qui est en tête de la gauche
c'est pour ce pour quoi on va se battre
et à ce moment là peu nous importe qui
vient
si celle inverse bon alors si c'est le
cas inverse il est clair qu'il ya des
situations absolument ingérable comment
voulez vous que des gens comme nous qui
aurons passé des années à combattre la
politique d'austérité et de rigueur dans
toute l'europe ont ensuite on aille se
précipiter dans les bras de celui qu'il
organisait il y aura une situation qui
met dix essais strauss kahn j'ai dit
depuis le début que c'était un problème
immense qui se présentaient à nous si
jamais il présentait strauss kahn comme
candidat et coûtent et mettez vous à ma
place
comment vous voyez faire un deuxième
tour il fallait dire aux gens écoutent
et vous m'avez entendu tout le premier
tour vous expliquez que l'ennemi c'est
la banque et les réductions de salaire
est maintenant deuxième tour a beau je
vous appelle à voter pour lui à qui
vient de faire ça dans toute l'europe
alors on va voir maintenant value
patrice l'actualité des jours à venir
parce qu'elle est chargé politiquement
avec une loi que tout le monde attend un
enfant tout cas des lois qui vont
concerner les français oui alors
l'assemblée c'est le retour du projet de
loi sur la sécurité dit loppsi 2
comparution immédiate des mineurs
extension du bracelet électronique et
peut-être assouplissement du permis à
points avec un amendement qui fait
polémique on est toujours autour de la
même thématique cette droite populaire
qui demande l'interdiction de territoire
pour les criminels étrangers alors on
verra au passage ce qu'en pensent les
députés qui reviennent à l'assemblée le
même jour huit au total ce sont les
ministres déchus du gouvernement qui
retrouve automatiquement leur siège au
bout d'un mois comme jean louis borloo
hervé morin ou eric woerth alors
mercredi là ça vous concerne jean luc
mélenchon à marseille cette fois un
meeting du parti de gauche sur la portée
politique du mouvement social vous y
serez et jeudi prochain ballon parce que
moi je dis je suis à la courneuve avec
marie george buffet puis à le meeting à
marseille oui on est là en ce moment on
y va on y prennent part
enfin alors dernis - alors
jeudi-vendredi conseil européen à
bruxelles sur fond de crise des dettes
publiques et de l'euro nicolas sarkozy
angela merkel vont défendre en tout cas
tenter leur projet de gouvernance
économique il s approchait
jean luc mélenchon avant ça vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure la victoire de
l'ump à corbeil essonnes donc échec de
la gauche qui pouvait avoir des espoirs
comment vous expliquez ça d'abord jeu ça
me rend très triste parce que c'est
assez pitoyable de voir m'enfin c'est un
le peuple a voté donc pas les mauvais
reports de voix à gauche se bat est-ce
qu'il ya pas dernier
d'abord le premier problème c'est une
abstention aux skrulls partout on disait
que l'élection municipale sélection de
proximité que tout le monde se précipite
pour voter 1 40% à peine
dans les deux cas il aussi noisy-le-sec
et deuxièmement le les socialistes
participent à nous lisent d'une manière
qui pour correct il mobilise pas où ils
traînent les pieds bon non cela marchait
dans le plus critiques des socialistes
quoi bah ils sont où je bois je les
critiques parce qu'ils ont une grande
responsabilité dans l'histoire est que
voilà quoi aujourd'hui nous sommes en
pleine crise du capitalisme mondial le
président de l'internationale socialiste
et premier ministre de la grèce il a
même pas résisté une heure aux
injonctions des banquiers ils sont comme
ça partout dans toute l'europe donc ça
me rend malheureux et j'essaye par la
virulence d'essayer de créer un autre
centre de gravité de dire bah venez avec
nous puisque savent rien faire
jean luc mélenchon merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce soir dans quelques
minutes vous pourrez retrouver cet
entretien sur france 3 point fr rubrique
soir 3 puis soir 3 politique la semaine
prochaine invité de soir3 politique sera
roselyne bachelot ministre des
solidarités et de la cohésion sociale
bonne soirée bonne semaine merci et au
week-end prochain